the close friend of missing Colorado
mother Kelsey Bharath is speaking out
for the first time it's an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning
Bharath disappeared two months ago today
and she is unfortunately presumed dead
her fiance Patrick Frazee is charged
with her murder Niki beti spoke with
Vera's friend about the couple's
relationship and how she believes it
came to an end Niki good morning good
morning good morning everyone
Ashleigh Cogburn says her friend Kelsey
Bharath had a lot going for her a dream
job a baby and a fiancee but she says
Bharath also often appeared to be upset
and she believes it had to do with
Patrick Frazee the moment that I found
out that she had been missing the first
words that came out of my mouth where he
did something to her Ashleigh Cogburn
says she saw red flags in the
relationship between her close friend
Kelsey Bharath and Bharath fiance
Patrick Frazee it was just always bad
about something she couldn't win it
sounds like she couldn't win the things
that he would say to her were somewhat
demeaning I remember one time in
particular she came to me and she was
just crying and Kelsey was this she's a
tough girl and I de can't remember
specifics but I just remember gathering
this person is borderline emotionally
abusive too right now Cogburn embarrass
met in elementary school and grew up
like sisters in Washington State they
recently lived together in Colorado
while Bharath who was pregnant at the
time with Frazee's child was working
nearby as a pilot who was kelsey Bharath
Kelsey was a kind sweet girl she kind of
had it all going on she was you know she
was really smart she was on top of her
game in life a female pilot she was
doing at all yeah she was doing it all
Bharath hasn't been seen since she was
captured on this surveillance video
Thanksgiving Day at a Colorado grocery
store with her and Frazee's now one year
old daughter
Kaylee Frazee was arrested less than a
month later and charged with bears
investigators do not believe he acted
alone
when Patrick was arrested what was your
reaction I mean I wanted to hold on to
hope that that wasn't the case you know
so you I grabbed Santa well maybe
somebody took her or maybe I think deep
down I knew Cogburn says she had at
times encouraged Bharath to end her
relationship with Frazee but Bharath
believed she could still make it work
Cogburn now believes Bharath would just
want to know her daughter Caylee is safe
what would you say to Caylee I know that
your mom loved you so much she was so
happy that you were here and I know that
if she were still around she would be an
awesome example of a person that you
could grow up to be like Kelsey
Barrett's parents have been granted
temporary custody of their granddaughter
Frazee has not entered a plea and his
public defender tells us he can't
comment on the case a preliminary
hearing for Frazee is scheduled for
February why is her friend speaking up
now she wanted people to know who Kelsey
really was she was smart she was
beautiful she was shy yet spunky and she
felt that had been lost in this story
him used to worry about these that
sometimes there are signs about an
abusive controlling relationship and
those can turn very deadly yes
unfortunately Thank You Nikki